e verde anche werder sia stato guardato
e chi è questo il
mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il suo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
challenge nel libro benvenuti solito
stories oggi video dedicato a poppi
playtime 2 che sarebbe il continuo del
gioco aghi onekey estivi noi non abbiamo
ancora visto trio non abbiamo visto
niente prima reagiamo al trailer e poi
giocheremo non sappiamo niente non
vediamo l'ora qualcuno di voi tra
spoilerato nei commenti di un nuovo
personaggio più qua il trailer vediamo
anzi analizziamo lube mia questo è
perché alla fine di poppy playtime uno
che noi abbiamo buttato a dio a chi
giovi questo è proprio il continuo a chi
vuol dire che abbiamo buttato giù per li
non ci stava inseguendo
[Musica]
ma è un gran pac credo di sì
rosa
[Musica]
qualcuno ha recuperato agli oag i quindi
vuol dire che non è ancora finita la
nostra ancora vivo di wight chi però è
nato un pò pazzo forse si
attendo cose terribili sono successe la
voce sembra quello di tipo pompizi la
bambolina erano varia della fabbrica di
giocattoli dda più a chi
posso guidare il treno sono già
emozionatissima non vedo l'ora di
giocarsi
da dove posso iniziare dice
[Musica]
perfetto tu sei perfetto dice in che
senso ma forse non sta parlando con noi
stato no con working forse si ha
un'altra area dalla fabbrica sembra
bellissimo
perché adesso quindi non scappi la mano
blu e ron bass numero verde magari farà
qualcos'altro 6 invece uguale magari a
qualche altro potere o non lo so
[Musica]
allora ha detto troppo perfetto per
essere perso immagino che si riferisca
ad aghi wired si però scusami un attimo
ma analizziamo attentamente ci sono le
mattonelle che sembrano normali noi
anche in luoghi che di solito è gigante
nero perché vuoi per le mattonelle
sembra così piccolo che anche i privati
si fossero in pizzolito così pure quella
mano è talmente tanto gigante da essere
una mano più grande diego e tutto
quanto è grande questa mano cioè non e
modalità che sembrava un grand pas
carisma né un pacco perché il braccio è
lunghissimo e anche snodabile sembra un
serpente allora da qua invece si capisse
che con il gran putt nuovo potremmo
anche ironia sì scendere calarsi giù e
arrampicarci bellissimo
ma sarà buono cattivo questo personaggio
quella mano
ecco ora abbiamo capito un po la
funzionalità della mano perna invece che
tirare l'energia elettrica come nel
primo bisogna mandare la tiene poi la
trasporti di verifica
ha detto che siamo in grande e grave
pericolo guardate un'offerta quello se
io girasole se ci fosse un'altra bambola
oltre a poppi ed è qui che il fiore del
papavero pace girasole
magari
[Musica]
ha detto lui sta guardando ogni to
movimento
ma lui che agguati o un altro personale
personaggio che bello quasta non parco
giochi tipo il tappetino quello di che
guido melis che cosa è quello con una
spesa di scivolo
aspettassero qualcuno guarda chi
è verde
c'è un altro aspetto qui c'era uno blu
anche uno verde no quindi vuol dire che
vorremmo inseguiti da due antigua di 1
bruno verde sarà il mini hollywood ma
dopo ho visto anche che ce n'è uno rosa
potrebbe esserlo rajae christie vista
sicuramente ma quello verde come si
chiama cioè noi non sapevamo niente
ancora della storia di antigua che prova
dopo che fosse solo agli guardi e forse
chi si mi stima grande essi sono molti
altri giocattoli pupazzi malefici
aspetta aspetta guardate bene c'è
qualcosa che si muove qua lo vedete
qua c'è una sorta di non lo so sembra un
millepiedi pipistrello
forse vuol dire che ci saranno altri
personaggi cattivi che si inseguiranno 3
antiquati pure a che vaghi verde è
questo sembra un bruco viola sembra tv
giocando come vuole proprio al maiale
4 con il bruco aprì anche hai visto ha
tirato tipo una manata
attirato una buona attivisti
c'è ancora questa mano rosa
ha detto un nuovo compagno di giochi
e chi è questo
[Musica]
così un altro ancora voglio rivederlo
voglio sapere che cosa ha detto
un altro bel
cattivo o non ci credo però mi piace la
capigliatura l'acconciatura il giappone
rosa a me ricorda un sacco a quando ero
piccola c'erano le bambole che si
chiamavano betti spaghetti avevano i
capelli
gli spaghetti depresso per karina
superficialità mi dice che non lo sarà
assolutamente anzi di braccio che ha
secondo tumore braccio si potrà prendere
le gambe schiodate e che poi un ragno
forse forse sì è vero
wow sei bravo pay
tv siamo troppo emozionato non vediamo
l'ora di provarlo eccoci qua allora
abbiamo scoperto che il mio personaggio
si chiama momi long l'ex quindi mamma
gambe lunghe
immagino perché oggi alle gambe che le
braccia rifiuti mene snodabili quindi
potrebbe essere la mamma di agguati o la
mamma di chi si misti ora vedremo qua in
questo gameplay di rob lowe chiama
proprio ma milan l'ex arrivati quindi
dovrebbe esserci già ma mi long l'ex in
questo gioco qua andiamo quindi subito a
cercarla partiamo già con il gran pack
rigo alla siamo torneo mentre il grappa
dove è finito vitale
vado ad aprire un poco migliore di una
randa o quasi sono delle tutine a luoghi
in cui mi posso trasformare in a chivu a
chi qua vediamo
quali sono delle scatole con anche i
luoghi dentro ma noi dobbiamo trovare il
nuovo personaggio mamino blacks ha
proposto voi avete visto la nostra
reazione ora il capitolo 2 ma fateci
sapere voi cosa ne pensate
pensate che sarà più bello del capitolo
1 di luoghi
eccola
babylon blacks e in effetti ha le gambe
molto lunghe anche dalle braccia molto
lunghe
adesso andiamo avanti vediamo se la
rincontriamo se è più grande infatti qua
c'è scritto mobile vuol dire mamma
quindi deve essere perché la mamma di
adeguarsi per quello che lei poi lo
recupera lo prende la mano e lo salva
rowe quindi dovremo affrontare non ci
credo nel nuovo capitolo affronteremo
agli umani di un altro colore che sei
messi ma meno tutelo pro chiaro che di
nuovo oggi vuole c'è anche bruno viola a
0 ovunque dicevo scriveteci nei commenti
voi cosa ne pensate del trailer del
capitolo 2 cosa non vedete l'ora di
vedere quale dei personaggi vi interessa
di più tra questi nuovi personaggi che
si vedono nel trailer io sto andando
avanti anche con loro so benissimo qua
invece sono dovrebbe si prende l'altra
mano la mano rossa presso la g già
quindi non dobbiamo più attivare niente
vediamo il loro problema perché infatti
l'abbiamo già completato il gioco ora
voglio solo vedere babylon glik
ma qui non si passa la fabbrica è
capitale finalmente buy e andremo nella
fabbrica abbiamo
avuto qualcosa qui è durata la batteria
rossa comunque una delle cose che mi
emoziona ancora di più di giocare al
nuovo capitolo di poppy playtime
esploreremo nuove aree della fabbrica
sapete che a me piacciono tantissimo le
ambientazioni sono fatti veloce e con sé
i propri playtime mi piace un sacco
perché proprio la fabbrica dei
giocattoli
abbandonata è bellissimo ma io vi sto
perdendo ma io non so da che parte devo
andare mai chiuso al meno e non bisogna
attivare l'elettricità e fatte già se
sono cosa li aspetta
ecco i e adesso possiamo cercare di
pavia ei balletti s sai che non lo so
proviamo a vedere di qua se la musica
giochi che vuol dire che fare quando sta
remando mobil home export non importa mi
sembra fuori se ti affacci dalla
finestra si vede tutta la fabbrica fuori
che gigante ecco la tua
gigante è un bug questo del gioco ma
riso ma prima di tutto amica fuori
possiamo andare quando questa è la parte
del labirinto quella era la fabbrica
quindi noi dobbiamo andare avanti e
raggiungere l'altro pezzo della fabbrica
e cercare bambino black andiamo andiamo
cerchiamo dove si va di quasi va allora
se qui siamo di qua la musichetta di
aghi e inquietante più aiuto perché se
arrivando non è vivo il mio bambino si
aspetta ho capito quanto sia qualcosa di
luminoso
ok ci sono autobus e dove sta
trasportando
figo dove sono nuotando che ora pensa
che mette trasporti alla fabbrica
devoluto pubblica è c'è arrivati o
come facciamo a vedere bambina blacks è
però bravo per fortuna i vuoti fai un po
tonto senza
troppa perché cercavo di prendervi una
resa a muoverti da ok andiamo sappiamo
su questo presenta potessero cadere non
si può passare da qua proprio a saltare
non ha funzionato
aiuto ma non sono stata una patta è
finita per fortuna che i modi e tonto
non mi ha visto
cosa gli vuoi che si mangiava qualcuno
ma ecco forse bisogna
preparasi in seguito anche qua dentro
come una coppia
per evitare possiamo dire dai sbrigati
speriamo che non in trip hop qual era la
strada sono riportate qui vediamo cos'è
non lo so c'è qualcosa di rosso
questo aspetto
ok sono che dietro di te piano news in
girata queste mani
aiuto attenta ok forse siamo nella
strada giusta perché se in quantità di
denaro però qua dovrebbe essere quella
strada pd non avrebbero no si si
aspettano credere
sì diciamo giusta dove anche chi non è
caduto
no non è successo ma c'è qui noi andiamo
avanti quindi quasi a mo vicini alla
stanza di poppi si attendo che non esca
fuori una delusione ma mi lega a
decentrare rosa apre questo porta no
perché non ti apre no queste dobbiamo
saltare in uno di questi rulli
trasportatori vediamo altro primato
sì sincroni va perché nel park erano
fatti dopo che non si potesse andare qui
non portano da nessuna parte
questo è il muro che succede se salto là
sotto
niente
nasce niente qua
bene quindi questa era
che abbiamo trovato qualche di robot è
la nostra reazione lasciato mi piace gli
voi non vedete l'ora che esca pochi
playtime 2 noi non vediamo l'ora di
giocarci fateci sapere cosa ne pensate
nei commenti e ora vi lasciamo a casa ci
linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri vi di locate su quella che
preferite buona visione ciao